today on the matt wall show as i return
for my excursion into the third world
we'll talk about the pain and suffering
of people in this country specifically
those who are deeply suffering because
of joe rogan's podcast really tough for
them also stacey abrams poses for a
photograph which unwittingly summarizes
two years of insane coveted policies all
at once and the olympics have started
but nobody's watching i wonder why plus
cnn hilariously mourns the loss of its
boss after he was ousted because of the
latest sex scandal at the network and in
our daily cancellation we will deal with
the nfl head coach who says that he's
the victim of racism poor guy we'll talk
about all of that and much more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
going online
without expressvpn
well it's like leaving your kids with
the nearest stranger
while using the restroom
most of the time it's probably fine but
you never truly know who you're trusting
why would you ever risk it that's why
you need to be using express
vpn every time you connect to an
unencrypted network in cafes hotels
airports basically any network that's
not your own your online data is not
secured any hacker on the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data what does that include
will include things like passwords
financial details you name it
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that hackers can't steal
your data just fire up the app click one
button
you're instantly protected it's that
simple expressvpn works on all of your
devices like laptops phones and tablets
so you can stay secure on the go so
secure your online data today at
expressvpn.com
walsh and get three extra months for
free that's expressvpn.com
walsh
expressvpn.com walsh
so i can't say where exactly we went
last week or what exactly we were doing
those details will be revealed in due
time but i can say that this project
took us to a third world african country
a very poor place very dangerous place
we traversed hundreds of miles getting a
good view of both its urban and rural
environments the one constant nearly
everywhere
was poverty and not the kind of poverty
we have in this country where a person
may be called poor and yet own three tvs
and a cell phone and live in a
multi-bedroom home subsidized by the
government and be so far from starvation
that they're morbidly obese
that's american poverty it's very unique
it's not third world poverty third world
poverty is utter and complete
destitution
there are no fat poor people in the
third world there are no fat people
period you don't see them they don't
exist
and people don't own tvs they don't have
refrigerators probably don't have
electricity
you know we saw entire families living
in shacks shacks half the size of
a standard garage made out of sticks and
mud and spare sheet metal
there were a lot of what you might call
uh i don't know third world town homes
which are look to be sort of shipping
containers divided into five or six tiny
units
for five or six large families to live
in there's trash everywhere there's
sewage everywhere everything is dirty
everything smells the people are
emaciated the children have flies all
over their faces crawling into their
ears and swarming around their eyes
out in the country people subsist on
their herds of goats and cows which
they guide to new grazing areas by
walking directly on the highway with the
cows
and if they want to go all the way to
the nearest town and they might have to
walk dozens of miles
and the nearest town invariably features
a small butcher shop set up in a shack
or old shed
with ambiguous slabs of meat
probably covered in maggots hanging on
hooks and spoiling in the sun
there are street vendors with poultry
little stands or random items set out on
blankets
and sometimes there would be a tiny hut
with a pharmacy or hotel or hospital
spray painted on the side now very small
pockets of the very wealthiest parts
of the main city did have retail outlets
and other landmarks of modern
civilization we had to pass through a
security checkpoint guarded by men in
military fatigues in order to access
a shopping center with restaurants that
sold the kind of food that you could eat
without contracting intestinal parasites
hopefully now most people didn't live in
those areas though and even if they did
they couldn't afford to buy anything
from them
most lived in the sort of poverty that
you can't really understand
until you see it by which most americans
will live and die without ever seeing
now the other thing about third world
countries is that nobody appears to be
in charge
there is no system
anywhere there's no infrastructure
this is most obvious on the roads where
stop lights and stop signs can rarely be
found i don't think i saw a single one
and like i said we drove hundreds of
miles
and where they are found they're simply
ignored everybody drives in whatever
direction they feel like going cars
bikes people
livestock dashed around you in front of
you
people driving on the wrong side of the
road
at random
we were warned to keep our windows
rolled up whenever the car was traveling
slower than a person can walk because
people will just run up and reach their
hand into your car and take whatever
they can grab
that's the other thing about a country
like this everybody wants to rob you
everywhere all the time and this
includes the random government and
security officials who you may encounter
on the roads and in the cities in the
airports
you're advised to have small bills ready
in your pocket to dole out bribes as
need be
and a few american dollars can get you
out of all sorts of jams in fact
as we may or may not have learned
i can neither confirm nor deny
you might encounter a situation where
you have to dull out a bribe as soon as
your plane touches down in the airport
but you may need more than a few dollars
if you happen across any of the roving
bands of terrorists or criminal gangs
who make a living kidnapping people
especially white westerners and selling
them into slavery or holding them for
ransom
that's the kind of thing that's a that's
that's the real possibility you have to
worry about in a country like this
we had a team of armed security to help
dissuade such attempts but most people
in the country don't have that advantage
obviously that's just one of the many
threats that will seem quite unique to
the visiting westerner there are others
like wild animal attacks we stayed in
tents for the majority of our time there
and two members of our crew had their
tent invaded and ripped apart by a large
and aggressive male baboon
and this event was unsettling to us but
not a surprise to the locals
it's the kind of thing they have to deal
with you tell them about it and there's
like they say oh yeah those baboons are
jerks
there are even more ubiquitous dangers
though like the water which you can't
drink
and probably shouldn't even bathe in
unless it comes from a bottle and even
then you can never be too short same
goes for the food
you could probably eat the meat if it's
cooked thoroughly and doesn't smell
spoiled though you can never be exactly
sure what sort of animal you're actually
consuming i think i ate horse ones but
i'm not sure
eat anything uncooked
including fruits and vegetables and you
risk spending the next 12 hours with
violent diarrhea
this experience will be additionally
unpleasant because depending on where
you find yourself when it hits
you probably won't have access to
anything resembling a modern bathroom
in summation
third world countries are hell
absolute hell
you often hear people claim that parts
of la and san francisco and chicago are
like third world countries
and as part of this same project by the
way we've binned all of the the
those cities as well
and actually it's not far from the truth
but in in a third world country
the whole place
is like the worst part of los angeles
the whole country is a homeless
encampment
we aren't at that point yet in our
country though the democrat party is
trying its best to bring us there
for
now in comparison with countries like
the one that we visited
that is in comparison with most of the
countries on earth we are living in
unfathomable luxury
most of the world is a horror show a
nightmare
we're living like kings most of us
if you can turn on your faucet and drink
the water
you're already leagues ahead of most of
the people on earth
we are comfortable to an obscene degree
most of us don't know what suffering
looks like
we haven't seen oppression much less
experienced it
we are decadent
and that has made us flimsy and weak
and stupid
so it was interesting
on the 30-hour trip home
to get caught up on the news in america
because i was a little bit out of the
out of the loop for that week as you
might expect
especially the biggest story which is
the effort to punish cancel and silence
joe rogan and it all began of course
with claims that rogan has disseminated
misinformation about kovid because the
people who run around claiming that men
can get pregnant and that the world will
end in five years because of climate
change and that racist cops are hunting
and murdering black people at random in
the street they're all very concerned
about misinformation
but then the the highly coordinated and
funded campaign moved into its next
phase which anyone could have seen seen
coming
which has involved digging up old
podcast episodes where rogan utters the
forbidden word the n-word
a word which you might hear shouted 45
times in a pop song without complaint
from anyone
but which a guy like rogan cannot say
even when simply quoting someone else
if your skin color is on the darker side
of the color spectrum you can say it in
any context you like
if it's on the lighter side you can't
say it in any context at all
now this rule obviously makes no sense
whatsoever it cannot be justified on any
rational or moral basis at all
yet it's used nonetheless to destroy
people like rogan
not because he said that word
but because he said a whole bunch of
other things that the ruling class
doesn't want anyone to say
it's all a pretense
this is why as people have been pointing
out someone like howard stern i mean
howard stern
for 30 years every day said things that
were far more offensive than any joe
rogan episode howard stern put on
blackface and said the n-word at the
same time
on camera
and he's not canceled he still has a
deal with
why is that well because howard stern
has been neutered in recent years and
and now he's convenient he's useful to
the left especially because he's
panicking over covet all the time and
pushing the vaccines
this again as i always remind people
this is not a double standard it's not
oh it's a double standard because howard
stern is not canceled but but rogan is
no it's one standard and the standard is
this if you are useful to the left you
can stick around no matter who you are
or what you say
if you're not off with your head
so they want rogan gone because of his
thought crimes
they can't say that exactly so instead
they claim misinformation and they re
they rifle through thousands of hours of
podcast to find a few examples of him
saying naughty words
all the while
the left-wing mob puts on this act
pretending to be to be somehow
hurt or victimized
because of words uttered by a podcaster
who
if they find distasteful they could
simply not listen to
but that's not good enough
the fact that he's allowed to speak at
all the fact that anyone is able to
listen to him causes them deep pain and
suffering they claim
now in the country that i just came from
people suffer because they live in mud
huts
and they drink sewage
in this country people suffer because of
podcasts
rogan himself apologized to the mob in a
six-minute video over the weekend
calling his bad language shameful and
regretful and expressing quote deepest
apologies
who's he apologizing to exactly
who is the aggrieved party
who was actually hurt by this stuff
that he said in podcast years ago and
which nobody complained about until now
well that's never explained
because by the way
another thing with all of this
um there ought to be a statute of
limitations
if you want to be offended by some by
something that somebody says you better
be offended now
because if they said it years ago and
you weren't offended at the time it's
too late now to decide you can't circle
back around five years later and say oh
you know what that thing you said five
years ago i'm actually really offended
by that i've thought about it for five
years now i'm offended
and if you didn't know that they said it
five years ago
then no harm no foul you survived either
way it's too late
of course i say that but i mean if
you're offended by something that
someone says now i still don't give a
damn
but especially if it happened a long
time ago too late
meanwhile the ceo of spotify daniel eck
sent a memo to his staff for now still
refusing to cancel rogan's show mostly
because it would cost him a hundred
million dollars to do so but nonetheless
groveling and apologizing um uh for
for the things that rogan has said he
said in part quote this is the the ceo
quote there are no words i can say to
adequately convey how deeply sorry i am
for the way the joe rogan experience
controversy continues to impact each of
you
not only are some of joe rogan's
comments incredibly hurtful i want to
make clear they do not represent the
values of this company i know this
situation leaves many of you feeling
drained frustrated unheard
i deeply regret that you're carrying so
much of this
burden
burden
what burden
you know i've come from a place where
lots of people have the burden of
watching their children starve to death
while their teeth rot out of their heads
meanwhile the employees of a
multi-billion dollar media conglomerate
have the burden of
joe rogan
it's all an act put on by soulless cry
bullies who are so immersed in their own
privilege that they believe they have
the right to control what everyone says
and hears and thinks
they're so invested in this imaginary
right
that they believe they have been they've
been personally attacked
if anyone is allowed to say anything
that they don't approve of
and that's why these people do not
deserve an apology
now i don't know joe rogan personally
but he seems like a nice guy and a
decent guy
unfortunately
these are not nice or decent times
you cannot be nice to the mob of spoiled
brats
their feelings are not important
their feelings aren't even real
i doubt very much that these people are
even capable of experiencing true human
emotion at this point because they've
been faking it for so long
when they come beating on your door
demanding an apology the best thing you
can do for yourself and for the world
and even for them is to laugh in their
face
and then spit in it
tell them to kiss your ass double down
and then triple down and then double
down on your triple down
what good will the apology do anyway you
may have noticed that in the whole
history of cancel culture
in the whole history of public apologies
offered to the cancel mob
never once has an apology been followed
by the mob saying we forgive you
never once
forgiveness is not on offer
they want the apology not for
reconciliation but for victory
they're demanding your submission
they want you to lie down before them so
that they can stand on your face and
plant their flag directly in your gut
and then claim you as a prize
don't give these vultures that
satisfaction spit in their face and
laugh at their fake tears
it's the only way
besides when you apologize
you're only pulling the rug out from
under the people who are defending you
the very few people who had the guts to
defend you by the way that's the other
part about this now i've had the mob
coming after me enough times to know
that most of your so-called friends will
will run away and hide cowering in
silence while the hyenas rip you apart
i've been through that myself only a few
people will have the balls to stand
beside you and defend you when you
apologize to the mob you're cutting your
defenders off at the kneecaps and
embarrassing them
they're spending their time saying no no
defending what you did and and then you
come along and say oh i'm so sorry i'm a
terrible person
you hurt the people who are trying to
help you
and help the people who want you dead
so stop apologizing these people are not
hurt
they're not suffering they don't know
what suffering is
life has never smacked them in the face
much to their detriment
so if you want to help them
give them the smack they need give them
a little bit of the pain they seem to
wish they could feel
that's the favor you could do for them
and for the world
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
according to the latest research 90 of
employers plan to make enhancing the
employee experience a top priority in
2022 after all a happy workplace is key
to attracting and keeping great
employees and if you need to add more
employees to your team there's zip
recruiter
their matching technology helps you find
the right people for your role for your
roles very fast and right now you can
try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
walsh zippercutter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you so this is a not a passive process
where you're just putting something out
there they're gonna go out and find
those candidates and bring them to you
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster no wonder zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site in the us based on g2 ratings zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day so find the right
employees for your workplace with
ziprecruiter.com try it for free at this
exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com walsh that's
ziprecruiter.com
walsh
walsh
all right um yeah
this n-word thing is
it's it's it's one of the great
absurdities of our time
that everyone recognizes is totally
absurd
and yet it's a rule
that that makes no sense
and yet everyone is forced to follow
because the consequences are so dire if
you don't
i mean i forget which comedian i think
it might have been bill burr back when
he was still you know saying things that
were funny and controversial which these
days he doesn't seem to do quite as much
i think it was him who who made the
point a while ago
that even saying like when you when you
say the n word
you're still conveying the word you're
still communicating the word to someone
because you're you're you you're causing
them to think it it's the same thing
with this it's the same sort of silly
thing we do as a the f word or the s
word
there's no r there's no real point
dancing around it like that because
you're still
if if if you're saying it to someone who
knows what that word is then you're
causing them to think you're
communicating it to them right and if
they don't know what the word is and
what it stands for then there's no point
in saying it because they're not gonna
know what you're talking about
so assuming your audience knows what the
n word is when you say it you're causing
them to think it you're conveying it
you're communicating it
so what exactly is the point
especially in the context of you're
trying to quote someone let's say which
is with joe rogan that's most of uh
those those examples that they dug up
he's quoting someone
so it's what's the difference between
just saying it or saying the n word
is there some
mystical
uh supernatural significance to the
syllables themselves
so you could say the n word quote
unquote but if you if you if you utter
the actual syllables
it what
does it cause people to spontaneously
combust well we know that's not the case
because i said as as noted at the
beginning the people pretending to be so
hurt by this
they'll listen to a song where it's
shouted 50 times in three minutes
listen to a song where it's shot at 50
times when you have people who who who
listen to the word and say it hundreds
of times a day listening to a song and
it was it's shouted 50 times and well
it's a great song
and then they hear a clip of a podcaster
quoting the word nine years ago
and they say oh my god that word that
word i can't stand it oh please oh
please
does anyone take it seriously does
anyone believe it
no
but joe rogan apologized to them
he apologized that's why you don't
apologize
all right um i got to move on from this
i could keep ranting about it uh
there's a lot of things a lot of things
were building up um a lot of a lot of
rants kind of bottled up over the last
week and so now i've gotta spill them
all let's start with this uh stacy
abrams who's the weird woman who thinks
she's governor of georgia
she showed up at an elementary school
last week
and um took this picture here we got the
picture there so there she is
um
sitting with a bunch of masked children
not wearing a mask herself
uh they're all all their faces are
covered but stacey abrams she has to
make sure that her face is not covered
because we got to see her face right
there's only one person in that
photograph
who's at a high risk of covid and it's
the obese woman sitting in the front
without a mask on
but no we got to see her face
but by the way it's always this is not
the main point but i do have to point
out that uh
these politicians who who are hypocrites
and refuse to wear the mask while making
everyone else wear them it's always the
ugliest ones too it's always the ones
who you're like well you know you should
probably just wear a mask in general
but she doesn't want to wear a mask and
all the kids are wearing it
and by the way she was there to read a
children's book i think this is also
worth noting she was there to read a
children's book that she wrote about
herself
where she's the hero and the the book is
called stacy's extraordinary words i'm
not making that up
so she was there to read a children's
book about herself as a hero
even though this woman has never done
anything significant in her entire life
nobody can at some point someone named
stacey abrams came along and the media
told us oh this woman she's so
incredible and said she should be
president
and we're all asking what who is she
what is what has she done why should
anyone care about her what has she
achieved in her life nothing they just
pulled her out of the blue
and she wrote this book about herself
you know i tell you right now i have
written my own children's book which is
called johnny the walrus which you can
get at johnnywalrus.com
and uh i will quite happily go
and read that
to groups of children and they don't
have to wear masks
so i'll make that deal
then the campaign the abrams campaign
they issued a
statement responding to the controversy
surrounding this photo and by the way
this photo was not it wasn't something
that somebody dug up
and put out there it wasn't like her
her enemies put it out there to try to
embarrass her
this is not like a joe rogan thing where
there's a coordinated funded campaign to
go find stuff on this guy no they took
the picture proudly she posed for it
they took it and
her campaign posted it online
because they're in such a bubble that
they they didn't even know that people
would react to it the way that they did
they didn't see i mean before uh a
picture like that makes it online it has
to it has to pat it has to be approved
by several people including probably
stacey abrams herself
and no one along that chain of approval
said hey wait a second um
you know
maybe this won't look great for her not
to be wearing a mask while all the kids
do
have to wear it
no one said hey wait a second um
the the person in this in this uh
photo who most needs the mask isn't
wearing them isn't wearing one while all
the people who don't need them are
maybe we shouldn't post no one said that
so they posted it and then they took it
down after a few hours when people
reacted to it the way that any rational
person would expect them to and then the
abrams campaign released this statement
they said it is shameful that our
opponents are using a black history
month reading event for georgia children
as the impetus for a false political
attack
what's false about it
was it is it photoshopped
were you wearing the mask and someone
photoshopped it off of your face
what do you mean false political attack
it's not even a political attack it's a
photo that you posted
she continues and it is pitiful and
predictable that our opponents continue
to look for opportunities to distract
from their failed records when it comes
to protecting public health during the
pandemic one of stacey's opponents
downplayed the virus while trading stock
to profit off of the pandemic after his
private chronovirus briefings as a
center another of her opponents attacked
mayors seeking to protect their citizens
and has failed to expand access to
medicaid even as rural hospitals close
this pathetic transparent and silly
attack is beneath anyone who claims he
wants to lead georgia so you see there's
no apology there it's racist how dare
you during black history month of all
things
to criticize a black woman during black
history month
well this is this is unheard of
um joe rogan and everybody else targeted
by the cancel mob you could take a
lesson actually
from stacy abrams and really any
democrat they don't apologize
they do not apologize
they go right back on the attack they
say no no
i don't owe you an apology you owe me an
apology and here's why
i could take a lesson from that
but really that photo is uh i think it
will live in infamy
and it it because it it summarizes two
years of insane
horrible uh
evil twisted perverse coveted policies
all of all of that could really be
summarized with that picture
picture says a thousand words and um
a picture of
the important one
sitting in a room with faceless children
because their faces don't matter
and the psychological effect of having
to cover their faces for years on end
also doesn't matter
we're told
now i've seen a lot of people by the way
sharing that photo
um parents and everything and especially
parents who who have their kids in
schools where they still have to mask
and uh they're sharing the photo and
saying unmask our children unmask our
children
i gotta be honest with you i'm really
tired of hearing that
especially from parents who have their
kids in these schools
unmask our children
no stop stop stop begging them to do it
how about you march into that school and
force the issue
i mean how have two years into this
if you're a parent how have you not gone
into the school
and said i am not leaving this building
until you take that thing off my child
in fact i'm going to take the things off
a thing off my child's face and you're
not putting it back on
you touch my child and i'm going to
touch you and you're not going to like
it
how have the parents not done that
two years into it you're still you're
still uh sitting back waiting please
take the masks off our kids please will
you please
well they're not going to and i'll show
you why here's a here's the
superintendent of wake county schools
explaining why it's so important to mask
especially young children listen to his
reasoning here it is
full mass compliance later down
their their growth as students right so
when they're
at it's like if you're a two-year-old
you're trying to help them practice for
age three and then four when they're
going into pre-k classrooms and then
from there trying to help them get into
normalized situation wearing masks
potentially in a kindergarten classroom
and so forth right so that's what we're
trying to do and it's
it is with a developmental lens and not
a you must do this or else lens
uh so we gotta we gotta mask them at the
age of two so that we can teach them
and condition them
he's being quite explicit about it we
got to condition them for the future
because they got a mask now in their two
so that they wear the mask when they're
three and four and five what does that
tell you it means that
he plans on those kids wearing masks
forever
he's planning years into the future
they're never taking the mask off
until you force the issue as a parent
which means you pull your kid out of
these damn places
out of these cursed places
or
you show up there in the building
in the class
and you take the thing off your kid's
face yourself
and you tell them you're not putting it
back on it's not going to happen
and it needs to be not just one parent
doing that but lots of parents
say what are you gonna do take us all to
jail go ahead
stop asking for permission
stop asking government officials stop
politely asking them to stop abusing
your kids
all right um let's uh
move on this is from yahoo it says nbc
is facing a cataclysmic loss of audience
for the 2022 winter olympics as
viewership tanked for friday's opening
ceremony averaging just 16 million what
a shame it's a record low for the
opening ceremony and a whopping 43 below
the 2018 games in south korea that
notched 28.3 million viewers despite
also dealing with a less than
advantageous asian time zone for
american audiences
um
and uh and there's a lot of speculation
about why this is happening
um
yahoo continues says the host country
china is a serious problem numerous
countries including the united states
are staging a diplomatic boycott of
these games due to what they say is
china's active campaign of genocide
against the uyghurs a minority ethnic
ethnic group
of mostly muslims in the far northwest
part of the country
yeah we're there's a diplomatic boycott
yet we're still participating in the
games
and so most people are assuming that
because of china's genocide and their
human rights violations that's why
people aren't interested in the games
and that's the thing people are focusing
on is like why why are we
participating in the games why are we
allowing this to happen why are all the
countries in the world coming together
to participate in games under the
communist chinese chinese regime which
is guilty of genocide and all the rest
of it
i i personally think that that kind of
misses at least half of the point but
we'll get to that in a second espn has
been discussing this issue
and uh that discussion has gone maybe as
you would as you would expect here
here's a around the horn the show around
the horn
and uh the host is talking about this
and like how do you how do you justify
this i mean how do you justify having
the olympics in china and participating
in it and covering it given the human
rights violations and here's how one of
these sports analysts responds to that
with genocide and human rights
violations
in the tibet region and against uyghurs
in china the international olympic
committee chose beijing while stating it
is committed to human rights
[Music]
today's opening ceremony which again you
will see tonight
featured a
lighting of the torch by two members of
the chinese olympic team one of which is
uyghur
j adana is a fan and then as a reporter
how do you reconcile and join this
competition while also considering
everything i just said
i think it's standard in sports right
now you have to have a cognitive
dissonance you need to compartmentalize
we've never had a more enjoyable nfl
playoffs in this country and
we've never had more people watching the
playoffs and yet it goes on amid the
ongoing allegations against dan snyder
owning the washington football team and
you know the continuous concussion
concerns and now the concerns about
diversity and the allegations and
questions about competitive integrity
even all of that and yet we're still
enjoying the games and who are we to
criticize china's human rights records
when we have ongoing uh
attacks by the agents of the state
against unarmed citizens and we've got
assaults on the voting rights of of our
people of color in various states in
this country so sports i think it is
possible and it's necessary more than
ever to just shut everything out if you
are to enjoy the actual games themselves
so pathetic
these people are so totally pathetic
there's there's no um
[Music]
there's no group perhaps more more
pitiful as we've seen in recent years
than the sports analysts
and that becomes very clear whenever
they get into discussing social cultural
issues
bigger issues than sports themselves
which is why i like most people prefer
them just to stick with the sports
obviously but they don't want to stick
with the sports because they want to
feel like their job is more important
than that so they chime in on these
issues and this is what we get that
genocide is comparable
to um legislation
to to to uh
you know voter id legislation
requiring someone this is what he just
said
telling someone that they have to
produce a license
in order to vote
is equal to genocide
that's what we just heard from a guy on
espn
and in spite of the fact that would
already be an absurd comparison on its
own but then in spite of the fact that
that same guy i guarantee you supports
vaccine mandates um which require you to
produce a vaccine card and a license to
do anything in society
if you live in one of these cities where
these
policies are in place
so and that's perfectly fine you want to
eat you want to do anything you got to
produce a license and a vaccine card
but if you have to produce just one of
those pieces of documentation to vote
now it's genocide
and this is all leaving aside the fact
that um for me that even the the greater
point
as significant as the human rights
abuses are
the greater point as far as the olympics
go and the fact that the whole world is
participating
is that china
by
by all accounts now
engineered a virus
which was then unleashed on the world
somehow
and proceeded to kill five million
people all across the globe
we've all been living with that for two
years
so china unleashes between the uh the
last olympic games and this one
they engineer deadly virus unleash it on
the globe and kill 5 million people and
and then they say hey guys i want to
come over and play some games and and
all the countries in the world are like
yeah let's go play sounds fun
and somehow that doesn't even make it
into discussion
all right let's go to this this is from
the daily wire
i'm trying to find some news story
that's not going to cause me to go off
on a
15-minute ramp but i really can't find
one this one's not going to be any
better this is from the daily wire says
on thursday 16 members of the penn's
penn state uh or university of
pennsylvania women's swimming team sent
a letter to the university of
pennsylvania in the ivy league asking
them to refrain from suing the ncaa over
its new athletic inclusion policies that
would bar leah thomas formerly known as
will thomas from participating in the
ncaa championships in march
they stated
we have been told that if we spoke out
against her inclusion into women's
competitions that we would be removed
from the team or that we would never get
a job offer
um
in the letter the swimmers note
biologically leah holds an unfair
advantage over competition in the
women's category as evidenced by her
rankings that have bounced from number
462 as a male to number one as a female
i didn't even know it was that it was
quite that dramatic number
462
rank as a male
number one as a female
my god not a surprise but still when you
see it on paper it really sends the
point home doesn't it
um and continuing if she were to be
eligible to compete against us we she
could now break pen ivy and ncaa women's
swimming records feats she could never
have done as a male
and then they can continue goes on for a
while we fully support leah thomas in
her decision to affirm her gender
identity and to transition from a man to
a woman leah has every right to live her
life authentically however we also
recognize that when it comes to sports
competitions that the biology of sex is
a separate issue from someone's gender
identity biologically leah holds an
unfair advantage over competition in the
women's category so on and so forth
okay so you see the problem here
and um
i don't mean to continue to victim blame
here but i am going to victim blame a
little bit
um
you're writing a letter in protest of
this insanity and that's okay that's
good
you're speaking out that's a good thing
uh yeah university of pennsylvania they
want to they're talking about filing a
lawsuit against the ncaa to make sure
that this male is able to compete
against females
the women the girls on the team don't
want that and so they're writing a
letter and they're protesting and all
that is good
but you're using the word her
in your letter
in the letter which is meant to protest
the inclusion of a man in your
competition you're referring to him as a
woman
and even of course taking a moment to
say oh we totally respect enough
we we we respect and we have so much
admiration and respect for her affirming
her gender identity
well there goes the whole case
you've just destroyed your whole case
it's out the window now
because
the only argument
against quote-unquote leah thomas
competing against the women
is that he is not a woman
that's the only argument
it's not simply biological advantages
that's that's not the point
because if you're going to affirm him as
a woman and say oh but uh but she has
biological advantages then the response
is well okay but what about there are
plenty of women who are just naturally
more gifted as athletes naturally
stronger they have a better build uh for
swimming and all that sort of thing so
all right so you're saying women who
have those kinds of biological
advantages aren't allowed to compete
that doesn't make any sense
and it wouldn't
because of course nobody would argue i
mean there could be
there could be someone someone who's
just the perfect specimen of an athlete
they have the perfect build for for a
swimmer
all kinds of biological advantages that
that other women don't have
but if she's an actual woman of course
she should be able to compete
so the only argument
is that he is a he
that's it
if you're affirming him as a woman
while
uh protesting his inclusion in female
sports
your argument is incoherent
you've cut yourself off at the knee caps
at that point
either he's a woman or he's not
if he's a woman then he belongs in the
women's competition
if he's not then he doesn't
this is the the needle that um so often
people who are on the right side of this
issue try to try to thread
because even people who are on the right
side of the issue and see it for the
insanity that it is they're still too
afraid
to actually criticize trans ideology
itself
and i'm here to tell you you that you
can't do that
you have to choose
either you're going to submit yourself
to trans ideology give up on women's
sports give up on on science and common
sense
and that's it
or not
but if you choose not then yes you are
going after trans ideology itself
you are saying
that when someone who is a man claims to
be a woman they're wrong
you are saying that transgenderism is is
an incoherent concept
that's what you're saying
and if you're not saying that then
there's no point in writing the letter
you got to choose a side
all right um let's do one more okay
let's we'll lighten the mood a little
bit here this is always fun something a
little bit a little bit more enjoyable
which is brian stelter on um on cnn you
know jeff zucker
cnn boss he stepped down last week
involved in another another sex scandal
and there are a lot of uh i haven't
spent a lot of time reading into the
story it doesn't matter that much there
are a lot of details that don't seem to
make make much sense i think i suspect
there's more to it than that he was
involved in some kind of consensual
sexual relationship uh with another
executive there's probably more going on
but whatever is going on there it's it's
sex related and it seems like at cnn
everybody's having sex with everybody
else except brian stelter he's the only
one getting left out and i think that
especially is making him pretty upset
and so here he is
on cnn we'll play a little bit of this
practically on the verge of tears
mourning the loss of jeff zucker but
also wanting to let the world know
that we need cnn that cnn is very
important let's listen to some of this
i want to end the hour with a final
thought and i'm going to go a little bit
uh
rogue here so bear with me okay
jeff zucker's departure was shocking
to the staff of cnn
but cnn was
not
built by just one man not by only ted
turner and it was not led only
by devsucker
cnn is so much bigger than any single
individual
it is about teams and teams of people
thousands of individuals who make up cnn
this place is not perfect
it will never be perfect
we will always have flaws we will always
screw up we will always have to run
corrections we will always have to keep
working to make it better and better and
better every single day that is the goal
but the people who say we're lacking
journalism
that we've become an all talk channel
that we've run off and we're all
opinions all the time
that jeff zucker led us astray
those people aren't watching cnn well
because nobody is they're not watching
cnn
they're watching complaints about cnn on
other channels because nobody's watching
it that's the truth
let's put the map up on screen of
bureaus around the world
cnn has all more bureaus around the
world than almost any other news
organization on the you know those those
are all the international airports that
covers the world london and those are
all the airport terminals in nairobi and
all the rest that's why one of the
network slogans is go there
on the day jeff zucker resigned
cnn aired more than
135. that's it that's not a very good
slogan look okay all right shut up uh
go
go there i mean yeah some people at cnn
they really go there uh
you know jeffrey tubin masturbating
during work meetings they're they're
really going there in a lot of ways
uh i just i i love that
these people they don't they have people
criticizing cnn they don't watch it yeah
no one's watching it
i understand that they have bureaus and
they're all yeah it's because it's on in
the airport
and that's where people watch it no one
else is watching it
he goes on for a while there because he
really sees this he's like he thinks
that this is
important to people
he thinks that he thinks that
average americans sitting at home first
of all he he believes that they're
watching his show which none of them are
but then he also believes that they're
concerned that jeff zucker is no longer
the ceo of cnn
but cnn they're gonna they're gonna keep
at it
and they're gonna keep having sex with
each other with reckless abandon except
for brian stelter and that really is the
greatest tragedy let's get now to the
comment section
[Music]
sweet baby comments is where you can
leave a video comment we got a bunch of
video comments while we were gone we'll
play just a couple of let's start with
um
with clip 12 though let's start here
with 12.
howdy mr walsh my name is caleb and i'm
the president of the texas a m chapter
of young americans for
freedom uh our pronouns are gig slash
them uh and we are super excited to have
you here on campus wednesday uh february
9th 7 p.m beth court ballroom tickets
are free at tamiya.org um but yeah we're
super excited that you're here and i
think
all of us here believe that
all of your sweet babies in college
station should be mandated to be at this
event
by penalty of death as the as theocratic
fascist dictator and cult leader we
think that you have the power to do that
and it would only be just or if you
think maybe even a worse punishment to
be banned from the show uh that's just
what we think we're super stoked you're
coming out thanks and giggum
[Applause]
uh yeah that's a a good good opportunity
to promote the fact that i will be
speaking at texas a m on wednesday and
uh i mean that's their suggestion that
anyone on campus who refuses to come
penalty of death i mean that's that's
something we could think i i'd have to
talk to the
um
you know the security there and the
local police to see if we can organize
something like that i'm not sure if
they're going to go along with it but
i'll be there on on on wednesday so i
hope you guys will
will uh will show up i kind of expect i
don't know texas a m it's it's
more conservative even than most
christian universities which says a lot
more about christian universities than
anything else
and the last christian university i went
to of course there was a mobs of
leftists screaming in the street in
horror
i don't expect that kind of reaction at
texas a m but then again you never know
so we'll see all right let's go to uh
clip 9.
sweet daddy walsh just want to say hope
you're doing something important on
these days off my brother
because you forced me to listen to
knowles
it's almost unforgivable you might ban
me from the show for this
but i never listen to knowles man
and i and i know i just said never to
apologize but that is one thing that i
will
i will say i'm deeply sorry for that we
have one more clip this is i love these
because these are always inspiring let's
play clip 10.
who makes twitter mobs fly out to handle
with rage
hey who's to blame
is a sweet baby gang
so returning the shopping cart and
singing the sweet baby getting anthem at
the same time we i have people
all across the country now
filming themselves recording
recording as they return shopping cards
and i
might be very confusing for the other
people in the parking lot but it's a
movement that we've started
um all right let's go to some of the
written comments this is seymour these
are kind of random comments from some of
the videos we posted and some of them
maybe the you know i've had to pull from
various places because we didn't have a
show last week but seymour fields says
matt walsh really just told guys to buy
their girlfriends and wives cleaning
supplies for valentine's day and i
promptly fell out of my chair laughing
at work well i think it's a good
recommendation because
you know i've been married for 10 years
as you know and i've learned quite a lot
about women and how they work and when
it comes to gifts what what they care
most about is is it practical can i use
it
that's why women they don't want
diamonds and jewelry and all this kind
of stuff you can't use that they want
things they can use
cleaning supplies
from naturally it's clean
jay bling says matt is one of the very
few popular youtuber commentators who
doesn't fall into the preferred pronoun
fantasy
i respect him immensely for that well i
appreciate that
but um it's kind of sad
that that's something you have to
respect me for
it's because i'm just going to call a
man a man and a woman a woman
it's that's not something that should
require any kind of courage or anything
like that
um
ml34 says matt i saw your tweets about
1883 i think you're being unfair it's a
pretty good show
yeah i did kind of i went off on on on
that last night this is one of the
struggles i have in my marriage with
with my wife is that i'm always trying
to enlighten her with important
commentary before during and after the
shows and movies that we watch together
and she has no appreciation for that
whatsoever and that's why i end up
putting most of this stuff on twitter
because i try to give these lectures to
my wife
um while we're watching these shows and
she's she's just not a receptive
audience at all
so we're watching the show 1883
yesterday on paramount plus
and um it's it's a western about a group
of settlers who are traveling across the
country from texas to oregon and it's
set in the year 1883 as you might expect
and i think i mentioned on the show
before because i recommended it
because it started as a kind of gritty
classic old-fashioned western and i i
liked it
and i'm and i'm thinking it's been so
long since
it's pretty rare that we get a good
western from hollywood especially a a
television show i mean the last good one
was i don't know lonesome dove
i'm highly highly critical of modern
westerns because they're so often
botched
and to such an absurd degree that it's
offensive it offends me but this show
starts well it stars sam elliott um
which is great casting
and it's a good show and then about
three or four episodes in it turns into
this soap opera
where the main character and the main
focus is this teenage girl in her love
life
and of course at the same time she's a
she's this tough as nails cowgirl
and all the women in the show
of course are tough gunslingers all of
them
and the whole show starts to focus
around these women
now you've got sam elliott
in a western
where they're going across the the old
the old west
and okay i know we're gonna do we're
gonna focus it on the teenage girl in
her love life
and then the latest episode was the last
straw for me because the caravan
they make its way uh it makes its way
into comanche country
and this is when the show should really
turn on right because keep in mind that
the comanches were ruthless warriors
they were the most dangerous and violent
indian tribe in the country
um and uh this is where we should be
getting in the show a whole bunch of
awesome intense battles between cowboys
and indians and it should be great
but instead the group meets up with some
comanches and they're all friendly and
kind and wise
and they speak perfect english
and they end up being like the the
superhero guardians for the group
and they're kind of following the group
from a distance and every time the group
gets into a bind they swoop in to save
them yeah because that's what the
comanches would have done in 1883 in the
old west that's yeah sure
that's
any time they saw a group of white
settlers what they all said to
themselves hey let's make sure let's
make sure we can usher them let's risk
our lives to make sure that they can
make it across the great plains
unscathed
and then the ultimate jump the shark
moment was when there was a there was a
tornado coming
and so once again the comanches swoop in
to save the the hapless white people and
uh and and and while the tornado is
going over top these people the comanche
and the teenage girls start making out
while there's a tornado and her hat
doesn't even fly off and then when all
is said and done and the caravan's
destroyed and wagons are destroyed and
all their supplies are gone and
everything and they're probably gonna
die
and the the father goes up to the
teenage girl says oh you know did you
how did you do are you okay and she says
it was beautiful daddy it was beautiful
the tornado was beautiful it just we're
all going to die now but it was
beautiful because you made out with the
indian during it my god anyway
i i was trying to explain all this while
we were watching the show last night
with my wife and she did not
want to hear it any more than probably
anyone right now wants to hear it either
well as you all know i am a theocratic
fascist and a beloved lgbtq children's
book author and as a man who bears this
extremely valid and important title i'm
always looking for new ways to expand my
influence across a nation that's deep in
need of spiritual guidance and also to
uh to profit as well it's another thing
i'm worried about so i ask you the loyal
followers of my regime to uh to show
your dedication by wearing it on your
sleeve literally so from this point
forward i will be releasing a very
limited edition patch once a month for
you to wear
because it's an utmost importance that
values such as saving abuela's returning
grocery carts spreading anti-panda
sediment it's it's very important to
share this with the public so these are
patches that you can wear
i think you put them on your like a
shirt sleeve
you could iron them directly onto your
skin
and i can't officially recommend that
but i will say that that's the the most
dedicated person that's what they would
do the future of this nation depends on
you inspire your friends and family to
return their grocery carts and question
the existence of pandas at the same time
my followers will also receive a digital
version of the patch for their online
daily wire profile remember stock up on
these patches uh the stock will be very
limited so make sure you you go pick up
the first release of patches right now
because we all know this world needs it
go to dailywire.com
shop
and uh get your first patch today also a
great valentine's day card um a
valentine's day gift as well you can get
a valentine's fur for your
for your wife get them a
matt wall show patch they're gonna love
that
um uh also speaking of valentine's day
we also have and there's no copy for
this at all really this riff
on how great they are
so our our copy editor was taking the
the week off so
uh what i'm being told is to riff on how
great they are and it's it's easy to
riff on these valentine's day deliwear
daily wire valentine's day cards
which are
i tell you what
they are great
the thing about these cards
that jumps out at me when i look at them
is i think
they're great
these are just great cards
so you can get 12 of them for 9.99
by going where i don't know because it
doesn't say
dailywire.com i assume you'll find it
there
finally this thursday february 10th will
be the world premiere of shutting
delivers first original film at 9 pm
eastern 8 pm central over delaware daily
wires youtube that means that everyone
can watch at least the premiere you can
watch it for free the suspenseful
thriller follows a young mother trapped
by her violent ex and his meth addicted
friend and she must escape to save her
children before it's too late it's a
tale of redemption to the beat of a seat
gripping thriller the film premieres
this february uh this thursday february
10th at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central over
at the daily wire youtube channel make
sure you click the link in the
description and turn on the notification
bell so you don't miss it because after
the premiere it will be available only
to the daily wire members we enter the
entertainment space in order to send
hollywood a message
that you no longer have a monopoly on
the film industry and the release of
this film is just the next step in
proving it so make sure you tune in for
that
join me ben shapiro jeremy boring
michael knowles and andrew clavin
thursday at 7 30 eastern 6 p.m uh 6 30
p.m central on delhi wires youtube
channel the premiere of shut-in starts
at 9 pm eastern on the same channel so
make sure to tune in before then
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
now the other story that was at the top
of the headlines while i was journey
across the third world was that of the
nfl head coach who claims that he's
being oppressed and persecuted by the
league which has made him a millionaire
as you may have heard brian flores the
black man was fired by the miami
dolphins after the team underperformed
and missed the playoffs
now the nfl is notorious for firing head
coaches at the drop of a hat if you have
one bad season you're going to be out on
your butt
you may even be fired after a good
season the most infamous such example is
marty schottenheimer back i think it was
2006 2007. he was fired by the chargers
after a 14-2 season
jim harbaugh was run out of town by the
49ers after winning 44 games in three
seasons and taking his team the super
bowl
and both of those coaches by the way are
white
so this rule applies to white and black
coaches like you have to win you have to
win a lot you have to win now you have
to win playoff games or you get canned
because the only thing that the nfl
cares about is winning that's all that
matters
now not all teams are very good at
achieving that objective but that is the
objective nonetheless
so flores he got fired
um like many miami dolphins coaches
before him
and he could have taken his lumps
and quickly gotten a new job either as a
head coach or a coordinator with a new
team
instead he chose to file a lawsuit
claiming that he's the victim of racism
he says that systemic racism in the nfl
prevents black men like himself from
becoming coaches even though he is a
coach and has been and has held a
coaching job in the league for years
notably the text of his lawsuit which
reads like a compilation of tweets from
accounts with blm slogans in their
profiles
doesn't offer any evidence of racism
instead it makes a series of
unsubstantiated and sometimes quite wild
allegations allegations which if true
still wouldn't amount to racism
flores also accuses the new york giants
of bringing him
uh of bringing him in for an interview
just because he's a minority even though
they had already determined to hire
somebody else
i don't know if that's true or not
but but it might be
and the reason that it might be is that
is because the giants would have been
following the very affirmative action
policies that were meant to alleviate
the mythical racism against black
coaching candidates that flores is
complaining about
so the league has a policy called the
rooney rule which requires teams to
interview minority candidates
even if they already know they want to
hire somebody else they have to bring in
a minority candidate for an interview
that's the rule
the giants followed that rule and for
their trouble they're now being sued for
bigotry bigotry against black coaches
because of a rule that was put in place
for their sake
the nfl has defended itself meekly
assuring the public that it's not
engaging in any conspiracy to prevent
black people from becoming coaches
and yet while defending itself
commissioner roger goodell
still issued a memo stating quote
we will reevaluate and examine all
policies guidelines and initiatives
relating to diversity equity and
inclusion including as they relate to
gender we are retaining outside experts
to assist in this review and we'll also
solicit input from current and former
players and coaches advocates and other
authorities in this area our goal is
simple
make our efforts and those of the clubs
more effective so that real and tangible
results will be achieved
translation
we aren't racist but if you think we're
racist then yes we're totally racist
because it would be racist to tell you
that you're wrong about us being racist
brian flores meanwhile is uh doing the
media tour trying to make his case here
he is with don lemon
i believe that the
the system is broken in the national
football league in regards to
hiring minorities and black coaches uh
head coaches and people in uh positions
of power
uh gm head coach uh and i'm doing it um
because
i think about my my two boys and my
daughter um
and there's there just simply isn't
enough representation
of people who look like them um
in head coaching roles in general
manager roles and executive and
president roles in the national football
league
and i want them to be able to uh
look at those roles i want them to be
able to to look and and believe that
they can they can get into a role like
that and that's simply not the case
right now
inspiring
inspiring poor guy too i mean
multi-millionaire coach in the nfl
nobody has suffered as much as him
except colin kaepernick and you know
the employees of spotify
it was really the the groups in america
in the world that have suffered the most
now yeah he's rich and prominent and
powerful but he could be even more rich
and prominent powerful if not for all
the racism
you know he so so this is a guy sitting
there saying yeah i've got uh you know
10 million dollars
but i could have 20 million if not for
all this
racism notice how he says the system is
broken with regards to hiring black
coaches but then quickly qualifies by
saying head coaches
why well because in fact there are tons
of black coaches tons of black
coordinators tons of black players and
staff at all levels
black people are massively over
represented in the nfl in comparison to
population size at almost every position
and every level on every team
black people make up 13 of the
population yet nearly 60 percent of the
athletes in the league
but there are a few areas where that's
not the case
which can only be the product of racism
he says
i wonder though
if the system is broken in regards to
hiring black head coaches
what about the system in regards to
hiring white cornerbacks
there are currently zero of those in the
entire league
there are also very few white running
backs very few white wide receivers a
few but not many
very few white safeties white
linebackers
the vast majority of the highest paid
stars in the league at most positions
are not white
is that a sign of anti-white bias well
no of course not
because under representation of whites
is never racism
while underrepresentation of blacks is
always racism
so you see how that works
there's no evidence or reason to believe
that any black man has ever been turned
down for a coaching job because of his
race the claim is preposterous on its
face
though that might change
thanks to the kaepernick uh the
kaepernick wing of the nfl
here's what i will say
and media matters are gonna have a lot
of fun with this
if i were an nfl owner
right now i might at this point actually
hesitate to hire any coach who is not a
straight white male if i'm running an
nfl organization the year 2022
i would prefer to hire a straight white
male
why
because a straight white male is the
only kind of coach i can fire without
being sued
flores and his ilk pretend that they're
helping more black people get hired but
the opposite is the case
whereas before race may not have
factored into the equation now owners
have to think when evaluating a black
candidate they have to think well you
know if this guy leads us to a 3 and 14
season i probably can't fire him without
al sharpton holding a press conference
outside the stadium
but if i hire the white guy
i can fire him after a 14-3 season and
nobody will care
flores doesn't care about that though
because this is all about him
being an nfl coach was profitable
but being a victim is even more
profitable
it used to be something of a joke to
call somebody a professional victim
now that's a literal occupation
available to certain demographics
they even offer college degrees in the
field
why do something for money when you can
sit around crying and make more money
and earn greater adulation for it
that's the calculation flores has made
you can hardly blame him from a
financial perspective i mean it makes
sense
but from a moral perspective and the
perspective of self-respect and dignity
which flores has chosen to forfeit we
can certainly say to him
you sir are
canceled
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy
boehring our supervising producer is
mathis glover our technical director is
austin stevens production manager pavel
vladowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matt
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
[Music]
oh so
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
let me out please
what is this doing now
i'm scared
no
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
you